bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches les
missions économiques qui fait le tri
entre les annonces et les arnaques de
l'économie
bonjour aujourd'hui nous allons vous
parler de l'écho la nouvelle monnaie qui
va remplacer le franc cfa
bonjour estelle bonjour olivier bonjour
à tous bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro
deux c'est cache une émission consacrée
cette semaine au franc cfa et à sa fin
annoncée le 21 décembre dernier depuis
abidjan en côte d'ivoire alassane
ouattara le président ivoirien et
emmanuel macron d'annoncer la fin du
franc de la communauté financière
africaine
on va écouter le chef de l'état je suis
très heureux aujourd'hui d'être à ses
côtés pour ensemble annoncé cette
réforme historique majeur aujourd'hui la
france a juste donc son positionnement
pour devenir le garant financier de
l'union
conformément aux choix faits par les
états nous revisitons ainsi des accords
vieux de quarante six ans alors de son
côté le président ivoirien a lui salué
une décision historique qui je cite
prend en compte notre volonté de
construire notre futur de manière
responsable
olivier c'est une bonne nouvelle ces
annonces
j toujours j'ai toujours ce réflexe
quand j'entends parler le gouvernement
de me dire info ou intox quoi donc on a
l'impression que ces jeux bush en rien
bouger et
on va voir ça avec notre invité tout à
l'heure mais on a quand même
l'impression que sur les sur les choses
principales on bouge pas donc il ya un
effet d'annonce qui est réel donc en
fait les la banque centrale africaine ne
sera pas obligé de déposer la moitié de
ses réserves en france ok maintenant la
parité avec l'euro reste fixe les
impositions en termes budgétaires etc
reste aussi décidé par par l'europe et
donc que la latitude est quand même
assez faible
alors justement aux libyens le franc cfa
va être remplacée par une nouvelle
monnaie l'écho les premiers billets
devraient faire leur entrée cours en
2020 le changement ne concernera dans un
premier temps que les huit pays de
l'union économique et monétaire
d'afrique de l'ouest le bénin le burkina
faso la côte d'ivoire la guinée bissau
le mali le niger le sénégal et le togo
l'afrique centrale reste pour l'heure
tenu à l'écart alors qu'elles sont
allées grande différence entre le
français file et qu on voit ça avec le
tiroir cash d'antoine bassesse
ça y est c'est officiel le franc cfa
c'est terminé critique est souvent vu
comme un reste des colonies il va céder
sa place à l'éco une nouvelle monnaie en
2020 on vous explique ce qui va changer
déjà le nom bon c'est vrai qu'à la base
francs cfa ça vous me dire franc des
colonies françaises d'afrique pour
finalement devenir franc de la
communauté financière africaine mais en
gardant le sigle cfa ce qui pouvait
faire de tâches avec l'écho au moins
tout le monde est d'accord
ensuite et c'est une avancée
significative
la banque centrale des pays d'afrique ne
devra plus déposer à moitié de ses
réserves de change auprès de la banque
de france comme c'était le cas avec au
franc cfa une dépendance souvent jugée
humiliante par de nombreux pays
africains la france ne sera plus
présente au sein de l'union monétaire
africaine
même si elle garde un rôle de garant
elle n'aura plus son mot à dire sur
l'économie des pays africains
quoi de plus normal je fouille pas dans
les comptes de mon voisin mois ar mais
attention s'il y a des changements
louable il y a quand même quelque chose
qui ne bouge pas les cours la nouvelle
monnaie comme l'ancienne sera toujours
aligné sur north est l'un des points qui
posent le plus de problèmes à clous
rouge est en une monnaie forte
elle pénalise l'économie des pays
concernés qui doivent lutter contre
l'inflation est loin de travailler en
priorité à la croissance économique des
avancées significatives donc mais pas
encore un changement total
décidément cet éco a encore des airs de
francs cfa olivier quand on regarde
aller les réformes et les mesures qui
accompagne cette nouvelle mauvaise qu'on
peut est ce que on peut parler de
disparition c'est finalement ce n'est
pas injuste on change le nom de quelques
ajustements
c'est un peu ça je pense en plus le
parallèle entre eco et euros
quand on a une monnaie qui a réussit si
bien en europe qu on veuille faire la
même chose en afrique me paraît des plus
douteux mais enfin bon bref
là dessus je passerai ch
je pense que ils ont faim monsieur
macron à essayer de prendre de vitesse
parce que l'écossé quelque chose qui
était fait entre pays africains et sur
lequel la france et l'europe avait pas
grand chose à dire
le projet initial c'était ça c'était
réellement de monter une monnaie mais
entre pays africains sens de ce en quoi
que ce soit et monsieur macron par son
annonce à on a l'impression qu'il apprit
qu'il a essayé de prendre de vitesse ce
projet est quand même de le rattacher
toujours à la france alors que ce
n'était pas le projet initial donc je me
méfie des annonces de monsieur macron
merci olivier on va continuer de parler
de la nouvelle monnaie qui va remplacer
le franc a cfa et cette semaine nous
sommes en liaison depuis dakar au
sénégal avec ndongo samba sylla
économistes et coauteur de larmes
invisible de la françafrique une
histoire du franc cfa aux éditions la
découverte
bonjour ndongo samba sylla merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous dans ses cages
depuis dakar au sénégal
on l'a vu en première partie d'émission
emmanuel macron et alassane ouattara
contacté à la fin du franc cfa en
décembre dernier comment est ce que vous
vous avez accueilli cette nouvelle
disons que c'était pas vraiment une
surprise parce qu'il y avait des signaux
précurseurs qui lui revient donc sur la
france est forte parce que il ya eu
beaucoup de contestations ces dernières
années et house un décor les autorités
françaises
vous voulez un beau coupé l'herbe sous
le pied certains mois panafrican et ça
certains intellectuels qui est héros ou
sur certains aspects symboliques comme
le nom du français par la présence des
représentants français au sein des
instances des banques centrales
africaines la zone franc et aussi le
fait que les réserves de change des pays
africains afin doivent être déposés pour
la moitié auprès du trésor français et
donc les oranje auront lieu sur ces
trois aspects d'un qui sont des
expressions ou le symbolique et qui ne
changera absolument rien à aucun de ses
cinq français parce que tous les autres
tous les billets en francs cfa sont
toujours en place le français va quand
même laissé place à cette nouvelle
monnaie de l'écho
comment va se mettre en place cette
nouvelle monnaie vous disons que le
français phare 22 baptisé eco c'est le
projet de alassane ouattara la présence
ivoirienne qui est aussi le présent
exercice de l'union économique monétaire
ouest africaine le moins et le présent
français emmanuel macron mais il n'est
pas sûr que les autres pays accepteront
que l'eia que la côte d'ivoire et la
france
le nombre de ces vins & co parce que et
couvre des bars et leur non retenu pour
le projet de monnaie unique qui doit
rassembler les quinze poulains cédéao la
communauté économique des états de
l'afrique de l'ouest est donc en
principe pour que les billes tous deux
français par puisque la nouvelle année
et qu il faut que ces pays-là
remplissent les critères de provenance
des critères d'entrée à la journée éco
tels que définis par les piles a succédé
à yohan limités et donc voilà c'est une
bataille de bassecourt suivre et
d'ailleurs même aujourd'hui les
gouverneurs des banques centrales de ces
pays d'auge hispano français pensent que
doit se réunir pour décider
la réponse qu'ils vont apporter aux
annonces faites par mme après héros car
de toute façon c'est un peu ce que je
disais c'est vrai annonces ou von
harnack finalement c'est à dire que
c'est à dire que le
le principal qui est l'arrimage de du
franc cfa à l'euro et est une aberration
alors c'est déjà pour moi c'est déjà une
aberration de chercher à faire une
monnaie unique parce que l'euro a
tellement bien marché que foule copier
ou au niveau africain
ça me paraît déjà une curieuse idée mais
arrimé des pays africains à l'euro c'est
une évidence bêtises on le sait depuis
longtemps ça ça ne permet pas au pays
d'avoir de la croissance
ça leur met des restrictions en termes
budgétaires alors que c'est pas le sujet
aujourd'hui pour le développement de
l'afrique donc c'est une bêtise et là je
vous dis je pense qu'en effet c'était
plutôt pour couper l'herbe sous le pied
des des pays africains qui cherchait à
se libérer de de la présence française
et ils ont fait cette annonce en
changeant non bon hockey et en cédant
sur des choses mais qui sont pas au
coeur du problème
changer de nom c'est bien ça fait
plaisir à certains sûrement rapatrier
les réserves toute façon pour ce que ça
changer quelque chose non la garantie
française on s'en fiche aussi un petit
peu parce que l'a jamais été
au final exercer mais tout le reste
fonctionne exactement comme avant donc
que c'est encore une annonce bidon
monsieur samba sylla un mot justement
sur cette parité fixe avec l'euro vous
êtes d'accord c'est que cette parité ne
permet pas au pays
d'avoir de la croissance en fait
survenir depuis l'entrée en vigueur de
nouveaux 99 et donc la croissance - a
enregistré en fait du revenu réel par
habitant pour l'afrique subsaharienne le
monial a été super asselah resterai au
lit peas le français pas c'est une
statistique qui a été donné par the
economist notamment mais ce qu'il faut
dire c'est en fait pourquoi maintenir
cet arrêté fixe
sachant que l'ebit africains de la zone
franc
comex que moins en moins avec la zone
euro a renoué au niveau des seins des
importations c'est à peu près 30%
l'opinion européenne de la zone euro en
poussant des importations deby qui
utilisent le français faire et ne
représentent que 22 % à deux pas de
leurs exportations
donc ça ne vaut plus de 70 % du commerce
de ces pays bas qui se font dans
d'autres monnaies le dollar
principalement avec la chine est donc
simple examen ne suffit pas et le fait
de maintenir une parité fixe ça joue
bien entendu sur le dynamisme d'ailleurs
pourquoi parce que pour maintenir cette
parité fixe coûte que coûte
il faut généralement que les banques
centrales afin de mettre le frein sur la
création monétaire
la disponibilité des liquides des
liquidités pour financer l'économie
et l'autre chose également c'est que
comme l'euro attendant un événement est
forte
cette annonce aussi à décourager les
exportations des pays africains et
surtout à limiter leur compétitivité et
donc on a vu cela par exemple où il ya
des années denis certains secteurs comme
la filière coton ont fait fait justement
en raison de ces facteurs la cherté du
groupe armor dollars messieurs on va
marquer à une courte pause on revient
dans un instant
revenu dans ses cages si vous nous
rejoignez on parle de la fin annoncée du
franc cfa avec ndongo samba sylla
économistes en duplex depuis dakar le
président ivoirien alassane ouattara a
justifié ce maintien en disant qu'il
s'agissait d'éviter les risques
d'inflation
est ce que une parité avec l'euro
empêche vraiment
l'inflation s'est pas c'est pas le sujet
le sujet aujourd'hui en afrique c'est
pas d'avoir une inflation à 2%
c'est ridicule donc ces espèces de
critères qu'on impose alors que c'est
des critères de je dirais entre
guillemets d'économies matures et cetera
à des économies qui sont en
développement cet idiot mais comme
d'habitude ça je veux dire on n'est pas
une idiotie près en france c'est connu
mais samba sylla une réaction à ce
qu'elle en dira oui oui je pense que
c'est tout à fait absurde comme l'a dit
olivier de l'opprobre des critères
disons déflationniste enfin portée de la
zone euro dans le contexte africain
parce que la plupart des travaux
montrent que les 2 d'inflation que nous
avons donnée sur 9 ans à ne sont pas
optimaux c'est à dire que pour les pays
qui doivent se développer des taux
d'inflation doivent être encore plus
important que cela
vous prenez par exemple le cas de la
patinoire depuis son indépendance en
1960 jusqu'à présent le niveau des prix
en moins a été inférieur à celui des
etats unis
ça vous dit que c'est tout à fait
absurde parce qu'on ait jamais vu depuis
que je sois développer son minimum
d'inflation et donc quand ils disent que
relisons d1 face d'eux des taux
d'inflation offrira de droite au centre
saoudi aussi les salaires des
travailleurs élevé des travailleurs pour
le plus pour la plupart d'entre 80 90 %
stable du réseau sur 30-40 ans et donc
ses salles à ses raisonnements et donc
il est il faudrait changer tout cela et
avoir des banques centrales qui ont
d'autres mots n'a par exemple
l'industrialisation la transformation
biologique crédit semble excité par
cette obsession autour de l'inflation
et quel intérêt à la france a gardé cet
arrêté la france à maintenir le français
va parce que c'est l'un de ces rares
instruments qui sont de protection de
ses intérêts économiques en afrique
donc à part la monnaie ce sont des
interventions militaires donc ce qui
fait entre guillemets les avantages
comparatifs la france et donc combien
d'oeuvres 7,41 n'existe pas effective et
le nominal
mais elle permet de maintenir un lien de
subordination entre les vies
africains et la france et donc n'a pas
été fixée manière de dire que cette
garantie est offerte à taux fixe parce
qu'on pourra concevoir une 40 y à peu
flexible et donc c'est un problème donc
la garantie devant la parité fixe mais
quand on sait que cette carence ne dit
pas il faut il suffit juste regarder le
budget de l'état en france et à chaque
fois il nie les marques et la somme 0 au
titre qu'ils ont des lignes qui
concernait la garantie de convertibilité
donc ça va le faire et on nous servait
de manière aussi on vous dira maintenant
arrêté fixe les pays africains offrent
une norme disons certaines faveur sur le
plan commercial
parce qu'à kemal le promettre ce que
nous avons envers les pays européens est
certaine manière est juste de bépanda
parité fixe comme nous avons avec
l'europe du moins de lait bio ronde et
plus avec les beaucoup plus flexibles
envers le promenoir aussi s'était tourné
vers la zone euro allaient qui sont là
vers l'asie vers aussi les autres pays
africains
on nous a juste de la france ou sur
l'intérêt de la france et depuis le
départ c'est c'est de garder la main sur
les ressources africaines
c'est donc ça a marché pendant 40 ans et
j'ai pas l'impression que tout d'un coup
monsieur macron la seul à faire donc ce
serait très étonnant monsieur samba
sylla l'écho concernera pour l'heure les
pays
d'afrique de l'ouest comment on explique
que l'afrique centrale soit pour le
moment pas concernés je pense qu'il y
aura des rêves vont en afrique centrale
mais les ennemis ne sont pas les mêmes
le mouvement de protestation contre le
franc cfa beaucoup plus fort en afrique
donnerait ce qu'en afrique centrale en
afrique de l'ouest aussi la conjoncture
du jour de ces dix dernières années a
été mis en afrique centrale
mais c'est sûr que tu dois à certains
aménagements et laiteries genre en
afrique centrale
un centre d'urgence en fait avorter les
réformes parce qu'en afrique centrale en
fait ces pièces est simple c'est que la
parité avec nous et beaucoup trop forte
et ses bimbos du swing exporter un
appart à part le pétrole et l'or le
pétrole ne sera pas toujours là et que
les cours du pétrole sont pas toujours
au beau fixe pour ces pays donc ça veut
dire que tant que système français fait
la cpi ne pourront jamais se diversifier
et quand il ya des crises c'est
l'hostilité pendant dix ans et c'est
comme quand comme c'est le cas
actuellement
donc en afrique centrale il est urgent
que ça change et je pense que les
dirigeants aux 6 et le message ce qu'il
faut aussi dire dans le cas de l'afrique
centrale sera un débit de la zone
saviola la mise en commun des réserves
de change
elle n'existe plus vraiment maintenant
c'est chacun pour soi parce qu'elle a
été constaté que beaucoup de pays
avaient tendance à être non pas de
visiter au niveau de l'apn accès et
piochés sur les réserves des autres
maintenant ce n'est plus le parent c'est
vraiment l'austérité il faut que chaque
pays puisse couvrir lui-même 5 mois
d'importations et cédera donc appelé the
reader est la question que se pose
est-ce que pays doivent partager une
même monnaie
sachant que le commerce intra régional
dans tous les pays de l'afrique centrale
crise le franc cfa est juste cinq ans
donc la question au delà de la parité
fixe avec une offre mais c'est est ce
que ces pays doivent avoir la même
monnaie et avoir la même production de
l'eau saison mais s'il a juste pour
terminer je voudrais qu'on s'intéresse à
votre tweet juste après l'annonce des
deux présidents en décembre dernier vous
avez twitté avec leurs efforts de
maquereaux et ouattara ont signé l'acte
de décès du projet d'intégration
monétaire entre les 15 pays de la cedeao
selon vous les causes ne peut pas être
considéré comme une première étape
ce projet a une monnaie unique dans les
cdo je ne pense pas pourquoi parce que
l'épilation sont inspirés des critères
de maastricht donc déjà mis en place ce
qu'ils appellent les critères de
convergence nominant après que des
chrétiens dans le train et donc quand
les vieux chais de france ils disent
qu'ils vont nous mettre mon niveau ça
veut dire qu'ils sont beaucoup
maintenant des écrivains de pauvres gens
cela parce que normalement la région à
l'abricot doit se faire sur une base
individuelle ça dès que chaque pays
remplit les critères de convergence
et puis entre cotonou en 2009 il y avait
que le togo est en brousse et liquides
et de présence continue d'où il devait
lancer les coupes mais à l'évidence nous
brûler beaucoup trop faible économie -
pour pouvoir lancer les qu il lorsque
macro et ouattara décide tout seul
d'aller faire l'écho de renommer le site
facebook
ça veut dire qu il leur remettra en
cause tout ce qui a été agréé jusque là
au sein des pays de la cédéao la
communauté économique des états de
l'afrique de l'ouest et donc c'est une
partie disons d'échecs qui va se jouer
entre le nigeria a principalement et la
france et les pays africains qui le
soutiennent à savoir le sénégal et la
côte d'ivoire
en réaction les dernières réactions
c'est ce que je rebondis sur sur 7 sur
cette histoire de monnaie unique
on sait que ça fonctionne pas on l'a vu
avec l'euro on sait que ça ne fonctionne
pas quand vous avez surtout des
économies qui sont très différentes les
unes des autres
or là aussi on cherche à faire une
monnaie unique dans une zone qui est pas
homogène et qui ne le sera pas avec et
d'eau que je trouve ça curieux quand on
a l'exemple de l'euro qu'on sait que ça
ne fonctionne pas qu'on sait pourquoi ça
n'a pas fonctionné et qu'on veut faire
exactement la même chose avec 15 pays
d'afrique qui sont aussi différents que
l'allemagne l'est avec la grèce ou avec
le portugal
eh bien ça sera la même chose la côte
d'ivoire s'est pas c'est pas le sénégal
le sénégal c'est pas le nigeria experts
externes
merci beaucoup ndongo à samba sylla
d'avoir été parmi nous dans
numéro de ses cages depuis dacca je
rappelle que vous êtes économiste et co
auteur de la main visible de la france
est la françafrique une histoire du
franc cfa aux éditions la découverte
l'actualité de la semaine olivier
consacré à cette annonce d'edouard
philippe de retirer provisoirement la
hache qui vaut de l'avant projet de
réforme des retraites
une décision saluée par la cfdt pour
autant olivier est ce qu'on est vraiment
est ce qu'il est vraiment abandonné cet
âge pivot
alors non d'abord il faudrait qu'on
arrête parce que cette idée spes de ne
pas de deux entre la cfdt le
gouvernement est grotesque pour des gens
qui sont d'accord dès le départ en fait
donc c'est un espèce de jeu de rôle
c'est donc ridicule
et puis on retire l'âge pivot on
l'appelle hd qui libre et on va leur
coller en 2021 ou 2022 je sais plus 2022
l'appeler comme vous voulez enfin je
veux dire il ya une réalité financement
qui va être organisé si les syndicats
apportent d'autres solutions le
gouvernement soit une conférence de
financement c'est c'est la même chose
que le grand débat c'est à dire écoutez
ce que dira edouard philippe sueur sur
les retraites jeudi les syndicats ont
participé
on a mon âge quand même dans le ridicule
depuis le début
soit on fait ressoude y je vous ai dit
on a fait une une émission sur les
retraites soit on se met autour de la
table et on cherche à changer ce modèle
qui aujourd'hui n'est n'est pas viable
bon donc mais au lieu de le dire et de
le dire dès le départ en disant on ne
peut pas on ne peut pas donc il va
falloir qu'on trouve quelque chose pour
que les gens qui cotisent toute leur vie
est quand même une retraite décente et
qu'on ne s'amuse pas réduire les points
poussée de deux ans deux ans enfin ça
devient ridicule
soyons honnêtes on dit aux gens la
réalité la réalité c'est que ça n'est
pas finançable à terme parce que ça a
été fait dans les années 60 où il y
avait de la croissance y avait pas de
chômage et c'est donc ce système n'est
pas viable donc cherchons un système qui
soit viable et qui convient à tout le
monde sauf que comme d'habitude on n'a
pas demandé l'avis à ceux qui avaient
bossé dessus et on a on assortit cette
espèce de réformes qui n'en est pas une
merci beaucoup à l'évier on passe à des
bribes des commentaires la précédente
émission était consacrée olivier à vos
prédit prévisions pour l'année 2020
alors voici les commentaires
sélectionnés celui d'eddy maqsoud je
trouve que ces prédictions sont fausses
en réalité je ne pense pas qu'ils valent
ce qu'il va se passer beaucoup de choses
les pays d'europe de l'est sont trop
favorables à l'union européenne est trop
dépendant d'elle pour sortir écouter ce
je vais très méchant avec les
commentaires mais
ce genre de commentaire me consterne ont
fait pas des prédictions pour qu'elle
soit vraie quand jeudi ségolène royal
revient c'est pas un désir profond
qu'elle revienne c'est pour essayer
simplement de vous faire réfléchir sur
des scénarios qui ne sont pas prévues
qui ne sont quelques souvent prévisibles
et essayez d'imaginer ce que pourrait
être à ce moment là le profil de l'année
donc ne me dites pas ses prédictions
sans fausse parce qu'elles sont faites
pour être faussés j'espère bien que
ségolène royal ne reviendra pas si le
deuxième commentaire celui de jacques
môme et saufs
il y a trop de réserves découvertes le
pétrole ne peut augmenter son avis voilà
là aussi on a fait un scénario ce
scénario c'était le la guerre avec
l'iran ces temps on commence à se sent
voyez des missiles et une énorme un
énorme noeud pétrolier exploser la plume
et rool pendant x temps et donc
résultats à ce moment là quoi qu'il
arrive même si vous faites des
découvertes extra et bien le pétrole
montre à vous l'avez vu d'ailleurs au
moment de l'arabie saoudite quand arabie
saoudite avait sur ses champs de pétrole
eut quelques missiles qui avait été
envoyée
ça bloquer la production de l'arabie
saoudite pendant quelques semaines
ça a fait monter très très vite le
pétrole qui est redescendue après parce
que ça n'a pas ça n'a pas définitivement
retiré la production d'arabie saoudite
trop longtemps delà du marché
mais voilà enfin ccd hypothèse on fait
des hypothèses pas je vous dis pas pour
qu'elle a rien donc ne prenez pas les
choses au pied de la lettre et prenez ne
prenez pas ça trop au premier degré
olivier troisième commentaires moundir
ben arfa autres provisions d'olivier de
la marche la fameuse crise boursière
elle et ouvre le cac n'a jamais été
aussi haut est ce qu'on en a parlé
la crise boursière non donc voilà
réponse à vous on n'a pas prévu de crise
boursière on vous a parlé de ce qui se
passait avec les banques centrales
vous la tendance apparaît souvent de
cuves boursière oui je parle de crise
boursière mais en disant que aujourd'hui
on est dans une bulle en bourse sur à
peu près tous les actifs qu'on ne sait
pas quand elle va éclater mais que
aujourd'hui les fondamentaux n'ont
absolument rien à voir avec les marchés
boursiers et que donc on sait qu'à un
moment ce différentiel va se rattraper
c'est tout ça ne veut pas dire et je ne
je le répète pour ceux qui ont des
problèmes de
connexion au niveau du cerveau le on ne
je ne vous ai jamais demandé de chanter
le cac
d'accord je ne vous ai jamais demandé de
le vendre à découvert
donc je vous dis simplement attention
sachez que le cac aujourd'hui comme les
autres indices sont beaucoup trop élevés
par rapport aux fondamentaux merci à
beaucoup olivier c'est la fin a de cette
émission merci de l'avoir suivi sachez
que toutes nos émissions sont
disponibles en replay sur notre site
arte france ce point tv on se retrouve
la semaine prochaine pour un nouvel
épisode
olivier un dernier mois eh bien écoutez
sur le franc cfa je dirais comme je
voulais 10 en début d'émission et bien
attention aux illusions